[Music]
Mandarin is difficult very difficult
even the locals say so one sound can
have many different meanings you do not
want to get the pronunciation wrong my
name is Tom Carter from San Francisco
I'm a photographer based in China I
arrived in China over a decade ago just
to go backpacking but over time China
has become like my second home
[Music]
I'm the author of China portrait of the
people a photography book I created
during my two-year 35,000 mile
backpacking journey across China I've
learned some basic Mandarin or what I
call survival Chinese but when I'm out
traveling into provinces they don't
always get me
[Music]
can you understand me now shank bill you
see and silently Tijuana how you go down
to Allah he you speak Chinese
thanks John Ben your English has
improved too it's really nice to see you
again and also nice to talk to you so do
you know where I can get a good picture
from up in the hills Neches I yolk and
oh me me yes there are many secrets what
time should we start out for the top
killing Jesus out John Wooden to Alpha
Thursday we start at 5:00 in the morning
that's gonna hurt me gwazi wine sample
tunisia - no need to pee do you it's
okay I will make it up to you by
treating you - beer fish in the evening
thanks son Ben you know me too well
CSU need need hide LT a wall
communication is of course the key to my
career in order to be able to explore
new culture you need to be able to
communicate with its people that's when
the barriers come down and you discover
the real China in its true beauty and
its secrets open up
[Music]
you